I'm tellin you Vinny no disrespect to  your dearly departed grandmother but my  aunt makes a pasta forget about it  your aunt lives in this neighborhood  seems kind of dangerous  what are you McGruff the Crime Dog come  on we're late already you say she lives  in this house here is the matter which  if any you're being rude let's go not  trying to be rude ace the lights are off  maybe we let's come back later he she's  probably just taking a nap after the  huge meal she just made for us go in I  don't have the key you should go in  first  not on she said she'd leave it open  finish stop being such a Strunz and get  in there  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]  Hey  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  surprise  you